we do kind of a matter-of-factly as best
we could show you both sides and the
turmoil that was happening the
amalgamation of [ __ ] I was about to
swear their ego on both sides you know
the kingdom of heaven is coming the
six-part miniseries recounts the 1993
standoff between Koresh's religious cult
and law enforcement officials that ended
in a fire killing 76 of Koresh's
followers many of which were children it
was one terrible decision after another
that a lot of these things were directed
through ego or through having someone
else to answer to on both sides you know
God has instructed me to stay here and
wait for his son while so much has been
written and analyzed about David Koresh
Melissa's character remains a bit of a
mystery even to her I play Rachel his
first wife who he sort of almost plucked
from obscurity which is 14
he decided did he have a dream about her
I think he did and in the middle of the
night she was in her pajamas that she
got in the car with him and they got
married and she went on his missions
around the world